The joe rogan experience.
So in your experience and all these other countries and will,
and when you,
you see all these different,
um,
you know,
regimes getting toppled,
you don't think there's any American influence and these things happening.
I think we're that good.
Really.
You don't think the CIA?
I've,
I've actually,
I'm a CIA nerd.
I'm one of those,
like,
I'm not a Gamer,
but I'm a guy who about 25 years ago,
started reading up with the Kennedy assassination,
gotten kept completely obsessed with that.
And then it just,
I'm,
I'm one of these guys,
I read footnotes in a footnote,
leads me to another book to another book.
You know,
I disappeared down the rat hole for 10 years reading everything.
So I'm really,
did you ever invest evidence?
Uh,
yeah.
Um,
you know,
my,
my feeling is we're just,
if history has taught us anything,
and if you read all of the documents from all of the controversial periods of
CIA operations,
we just don't seem to be very good at these things.
And,
and everybody rats and writes a book about it,
but immediately afterwards,
so if it went well,
you can be sure you'd be reading about or would have been leaked to a magazine
by now.
You know,
it's,
I just,
I don't think that's so sad.
I don't think we're that good.
Uh,
and I,
I certainly don't think we have much of an appetite for controlling the universe
that the group we're doing it.
We seem to be,
we work very working very hard to hold the down.
MMM.
So you think there's speculation about the CIA being involved?
Like they're probably just very,
very peripherally involved and there's just shit happening no matter what their
major CIA operations going on right now without it,
without doubt.
But I think this notion that there's an office somewhere where the whole fate of
the world is sort of decided what countries are good,
it would fade over the next 10 years.
Uh,
we're just not that good.
And we're not definitely not that secure.
There's always three people know about something.
It's a greatest argument about the Kennedy's,
you know,
the nine 11 conspiracy theory idiots.
Um,
the Kennedy assassination,
uh,
looney tunes.
Um,
if basically in this country of three people,
more than three people know about a thing,
one of them is going to be on the stand crying about it.
The other guy is going to be writing a book about it and maybe two guys will
keep their mouth shut.
I think today,
I don't think during the time of the Kennedy assassination,
it would have been that difficult to hide things.
I think,
uh,
things were less,
much less transparent back then then were today you have it his death with
greater,
but history,
you know,
eventually if you're willing to wait around something,
or my VA to my view,
if you're willing to wait around or every boring grim detail will,
will eventually come out.
And,
and if you,
as in the Kennedy assessed,
so someone,
I don't know who said it,
they described the mafia theory as the halfway house for failed conspiracy
theorist.
It's like after you've decided to CIA didn't do it.
I did it.
It's like,
yeah,
well it was the mafia,
you know,
and there's of course there's all this great evidence to support that theory,
but,
but ultimately I'm of the Oswald got a lucky shot flaring up.
I read best evidence and that's one of the reasons why I first started believing
that there was some sort of a conspiracy that was,
uh,
one of the,
one of the first things that I saw that made me really reconsider.
But later in life,
the thing that really got me was the Northwoods document.
If you never heard of that,
it's something that they drafted in the 1960s or 1960 [inaudible] 61 or 62 where
Kennedy actually vetoed it.
And all the joint chiefs of Staff,
the Joint Chiefs of staff signed it.
And then we're going to have fake American,
uh,
terror attacks.
We're going to get a,
a plane and we're going to have a drone plane exploded and say a bunch of people
died and they were going to attack Guantanamo Bay and they were going to arm
Cuban friendlies to attack Guantanamo Bay.
Cause we wanted to go to this was this,
was this a Cuban missile crisis era?
There were,
there were so many complete,
this is what it,
to me,
what's interesting about Kennedy's assassination conspiracy.
There was so much it wacky shit going on around that time.
So much of it embarrassing.
Um,
criminal scary,
funny,
really silly going on at that time that in fact,
the least interesting thing about the entire,
you know,
big picture of the Kennedy assassination is the actual assassination itself
because what everybody else was up to at the time and covering up where it's
just like right out of a movie and CIA get his meeting with Johnny Roselli and
all these like mafia guys that blackout Castro,
uh,
you know,
there,
there was just so much other embarrassing shit going on that in many ways those
stories and where they lead or a lot more entertaining and complex and,
and fun.
Then then a story of a guy,
you know,
shooting a president.
So if you believe that Lee Harvey Oswald acted alone,
what are you doing about when you see the,
like the Oliver Stone movie?
Does that drive you fucking crazy?
It would've,
I would've liked to fill in a lot better.
Um,
if they just stuck with a historical record and he invented scenes and
characters,
you know,
which I thought was as a,
as a,
as a Kennedy assassination plot and character didn't exist.
Right.
And there were just certain things we're just do mention that the garrison jury
was out for like 30 seconds.
He's mentioned the Jim Garrison is a man of many interesting local,
uh,
a man with an interesting pass,
let's put it that way and not go away.
He did not,
uh,
not,
a reputation that was debatable,
let's put it that way.
Um,
which is never good.
The case was bad.
I mean he put a lot of very interesting stuff together and there was an,
all of it was like fascinating and a lot of ways,
a lot of it was,
it was almost more interesting than the,
than that there wasn't,
I don't believe in the octopus theory.
I think you had a lot of really interesting,
very spooky characters who've been doing a lot of really sinister,
uh,
an interesting shit for a long time.
Whether or not they were actually involved in the Kennedy assassination is
almost moot because there were up to some really other wacky stuff.
Did the magic bullet theory bother you at all?
I think if you talk,
and I have talked to people who served in combat for a long time,
the story,
the buddy who gets around through the front of his helmet,
it,
it travels around subcutaneously around the skull and it enters out the back
without hurting the guy.
Uh,
is it everybody's got shit happens,
shit happens.
I am,
I am willing to believe that magic bullet theory.
I would be willing to believe it except for the fact that they came up with it
because the guy got hit with a ricochet under the bridge.
And so they had to attribute everything to three shots.
And I was like,
ah,
that she just seems like fucking shifty lodge.
I Dunno what is what they're called.
But when you've eliminated all the other suspects,
uh,
you know,
you were left with the likely truth,
I think.
And I,
I,
to my satisfaction and I've kind of eliminated the other suspects.
Woody Harrelson,
his dad didn't have any part of it grass,
wasn't he like rumored to be one of the shooters?
It's a,
I mean,
you know,
it wasn't that part of this,
of course Howard Hunt was supposed to be there.
You know,
everybody's there.
Mcdonald's is there.
Why is that so sexy?
Walking unbelievable.
So badly foot,
loch ness,
monster,
Ua foes candidate,
the whole deal.
It's way more fun to think that Lee Harvey Oswald was a Pantsuit,
but remember,
he was a really interesting guy.
If you,
I think the book that got it close got it most right.
Uh,
was a work of fiction.
The Libra by Don Delillo lower,
it's really gets inside,
uh,
Oswald's head.
I mean,
Oswald was a guy who,
who,
uh,
his favorite show is a teenager was,
I led three lives about an undercover FBI agent.
He was an intelligent,
he was a spy junkie in today's world.
He would have been a Gamer and we're not a game.
He wanted to be.
He,
he was a guy who kind of wanted to,
to be,
uh,
to do big things and he tried very hard.
He wanted to be super secret KGB agent.
He wanted to be super secret,
you know,
wanting to be a marine.
He probably volunteered to the FBI a couple of times.
He was just a guy who wanted to do something big.
Um,
so I don't have a problem buying it.
So you had no problem with the allegations of them fixing autopsy photos?
I have problems with all of it cause I was lost in it for 10 years.
But the Kennedy family had very good reason to ask for,
you know,
the brain.
I mean he had Addison's disease and the implications of,
of Addison's disease,
uh,
towards the,
the Kennedy history were not favorable.
You know,
apparently,
I don't know.
But apparently it has been said that he had multiple bouts of syphilis.
This is,
you know,
you don't want,
the family didn't want to press and people,
they want this part of the record.
There was a lot of sense.
Syphilis Holla at your boy
that was worth it.
Amphetamines in large doses at that early.
It is point and who knows what.
He's really a,
he had a doctor,
Max Jacobson I believe,
I believe was the name.
He did have a doctor who would shoot him with the vitamin.
I think B12 and amphetamine according to one of the B12 mixed with speed.
That's how that do is not uncommon at certain levels.
It was very,
you know,
a society thing to do back then a five hour energy drink.
That's what it is.
The 12 and a lot of people didn't even know there was,
he was the original doctor.
He was known as Dr Feelgood and that's where the name came from.
Dr I believe it was doctor Max Jacobson night.
I don't know.
Legendary.
Wow.
Sort of doctor to the stars back in them Warhol and Kennedy's disease.
What did it happen?
It was at a motor skill thing.
What is it that I don't but,
but apparently there were up there are in the symptoms,
the possible symptoms.
I think there can be emotional,
an emotional content to the disease,
so theoretically could have affected his judgment.
It was,
it was unflattering.
I believe he was in a lot of,
this was the guide,
a lot of pain to supposedly,
right.
Yeah.
But back then you just didn't want to talk about these things and,
and uh,
I think a lot of people,
uh,
ran around in circles covering things up for their own reasons and in fact most
of them had really terrible things to cover up that back then thing is really
fascinating when you think about it.
It's not that long ago I was,
I was alive.
I remember being sent home from school when Kennedy was killed.
Kennedy was killed it.
Um,
but I,
I,
you know,
I go for the simple explanation much of the time.
That's the good move.
Um,
I mean myself,
I keep the crazy open.
I opened the door for crazy because I've seen some things.
I leave it open.
I,
but I,
I agree with you.
Most of the time I go with a simple door with crop circles and Ufo shows in the
loch ness monster.
And Big Foot.
Most of the time I go for the simple door.
People are full of Shit and that story socks,
that's how I usually go,
but I leave the door for crazy.
Okay.
[inaudible]
cheer up fucking human being.